بدا وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن
والرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس محادثات في
رام الله قبل قليل وهذه الصور وردتنا قبل
قليل من رام الله لبدايه هذه المحادثات
بين الجانبين ومعنا من رام الله مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد العمري وليد ما ابرز الملفات
التي سيجري التركيز عليها في هذه
المباحثات فعلا وصول بلينكن تقدم ساعه عن
الموعد على ما يبدو بسبب ان الرئيس
الفلسطيني سيتوجه لحضور القمه مع الرئيس
المصري والعاهل الاردني في العقبه عصر هذا
اليوم وقد وصل الى رام الله والان
الاجتماع ملتئم في مقر الرئاسه في
المقاطعه برام الله الملفات التي سيتم
تناولها اولا بلينكن يريد من السلطه
الفلسطينيه ان تاخذ دورا في اداره قطاع
غزه في اليوم التالي للحرب ولكنه بالوقت
نفسه يطالبها بان تجري اصلاحات على طريق
ادائها وايضا على اجهزتها بالكامل بما
فيها حكومتها هذا موضوعان هامان الجانب
الفلسطيني من ناحيته الرئيس سيطالب بوقف
فوري للحرب على غزه وبتقديم كافه
المساعدات الانسانيه اللازمه ومضاعفتها
وخروج وانسحاب القوات الاسرائيليه منها
هذه هي الامور لكن هناك الموضوع الجديد
الذي كان بلينكن قد تحدث عنه بالامس وهو
الطاقم الذي سياتي من الامم المتحده الى
قطاع غزه هم يريدون من هذا الطاقم ان ان
يكون ايضا للسلطه الفلسطينيه دورا في هذا
الشان لكن واضح بان الامر لا يتوقف كما
يبدو لا على الرغبه الامريكيه ولا على
الموقف الفلسطيني وانما ايضا على الموقف
الاسرائيلي الرافض اصلا لاعطاء اي دور
للسلطه الفلسطينيه السلطه الفلسطينيه من
ناحيتها غير قادره
وال ولا تستطيع اصلا ان ترسل اي من
موظفيها او قواتها الى قطاع غزه لتحمل
مسؤوليه الدمار والقتل الذي زرعته اسرائيل
في القطاع وما زالت في ذات الوقت هناك
تعبير عن المعارضه في الش الشارع
الفلسطيني لزياره بلينكن ولمهم ته يرون
بانها تاتي انما ان الولايات المتحده
متهمه بنظرهم بانها مع اسرائيل في هذه
الحرب لذلك هنا هذا التجمع الذي بدا قبل
قليل مع وصول بلينكن في ميدان المناره
والذي يهتفون فيه ضد استقباله وضد
الولايات المتحده ويطالبون بوقف تام
لاطلاق النار وهؤلاء يطالبون ايضا بموقف
فلسطيني وعربي واضح وداعم لقطاع غزه يحمل
اسرائيل بكامل المسؤوليه عما الى اليه
الوضع هناك ويعتبرون بان الولايات المتحده
هي شريك لاسرائيل في هذه الحرب على كل حال
زياره بلينكن ولقائه بالرئيس الفلسطيني هي
المره الخامسه الذي يلتقي بها الرئيس
الفلسطيني لكنها الثالثه التي يصل فيها
الى رام الله منذ بدايه هذه الحرب وهو
يحمل عمليا نفس المواقف كما ان بلينكن
سيطلع الجانب الفلسطيني على الموقف
الاسرائيلي من
تحويل عائدات الضرائب التي تحتجزها
اسرائيل وترفض تحويلها للسلطه الفلسطينيه
كما انه سيتم اطلاعه على الوضع الفلسطيني
الداخلي سواء على مستوى السلطه نفسها
والضعف التي تعاني منه واحتمالات عجزها في
دفع الرواتب لموظفيها بسبب احتجاز اسرائيل
لهذه الاموال وايضا الوضع الداخلي
والاعتداءات المتكرره سواء لعصابات
المستوطنين او ما يواصله الجيش الاسرائيلي
في الضفه الغربيه من تصعيد واضح ومتواصل
على نحو خطير وهذا الموضوع بالذات ياتي
على خلفيه تقارير امريكيه وكذلك من قاده
ومسؤولين امنيين وعسكريين اسرائيليين
حذروا حكومه نتنياهو من ان الضفه الغربيه
باتت على شفا الانفجار بسبب الوضع الموجود
فيها وان
محاوله تحرير الاموال من شانها ان تنزع
فتيل الانفجار في المرحله الحاليه لان
احتجازها سيت سبب ايضا في حاله عجز وربما
انهيار للسلطه الفلسطينيه هذه هي المواضيع
التي سيتم بحثها الجانب الفلسطيني يتوقع
ان يعود على موقفه بضروره ان تكون هناك
عمليه سياسيه تنتهي بانهاء الاحتلال
واقامه دوله فلسطينيه
كمظاهر وان لا يقتصر الامر على ارسال طاقم
للامم المتحده للوقوف على الدمار الهائل
وواقع الحال في قطاع غزه تمهيدا لعوده
سكانه في ح اتيح ذلك وتوقفت الحرب
الاسرائيليه وزير الخارجيه بلينكن متوقع
ان يعود ايضا على الموقف الامريكي بهذا
الخصوص شكرا لك وليد العمري مدير مكتب
الجزيره كنت معنا من رام الله